this week has been such an incredible
week um the whole the whole week we've
been meeting film industry luminaries
and they're telling coming up and
telling us that they've seen our film
and that they like it and and you're
trying to talk to them with a straight
face and the whole time in the back of
your head your head is spinning because
you're thinking oh my god i'm talking to
the dp of mean streets or the editor of
of et and i mean it's just it's been
incredible the experience and so i want
to thank the academy for this experience
and and i'm sitting here with with this
award in my hand so i really want to
thank all of you for that
i want to thank everyone who helped make
this film the actors sumrat chakraberti
who was you saw here he also did the
music mina serendip she's here she um
was lead actress in rithik oil the sun
he is only 10 years old and he's from
you grew up in texas but he's speaking
with an indian accent and
he was just incredible um
my crew from the university of texas uh
nina
israel my dp kim hall allison jenny or
zan there's there's so many names
the city of giddings just everybody at
ut and
most importantly uh my mom and dad
i made this parent this film for you
guys
as a tribute and
and radhika my wife i shot this film
just two weeks before we got married
and
i don't know where things go from here
with all this but um
i'm so glad i got to share this high
with you
thank you all so much